zdf heute live herzlich willkommen
montag erster märz viele haben angst vor
einer dritten welle aber gleichzeitig
tut sich was im land in zwei
bundesländern zum beispiel öffnen ab
heute wieder die zoos an vielen orten
ist der einzelhandel wieder geöffnet
unter bestimmten voraussetzungen mit
vorheriger terminvergabe diffus pfleger
innen sind wieder da und auch sie die
friseure wie hier in diesem salon in
berlin kamen die kunden teilweise sogar
direkt ab mitternacht die nachfrage nach
einem neuen haarschnitt war riesig
genauso groß wie die freude denn 75 tage
war immerhin selber schneiden oder
wildwuchs an gesagt jetzt sind die
termine heiß begehrt wieder ein bisschen
normalität natürlich unter strengen
auflagen und auch sie dürfen wieder
öffnen blumenläden und gartencenter
zumindest in einigen bundesländern auch
hier unter verschiedenen voraussetzungen
die kunden hier in schleswig-holstein
freut es sehr denn mit frischen pflanzen
und blumen kehrt auch ein bisschen farbe
in den oft tristen corona alltag zurück
mitten im gartencenter ist auch meine
kollegin unserer reporterin luisa houben
in magdeburg und sie wird uns gleich
schildern wie der tag dort heute
gelaufen ist
außerdem mit dabei ist die physikerin
doktor viola prise man eine der
wissenschaftlerinnen die auch
regierungen berät schön gut namen frau
doktor prise man sie sind eine der
wissenschaftlerinnen am max planck
institut für dynamik und
selbstorganisation in göttingen leiten
dort eine forschungsgruppe und waren im
verlauf der pandemie immer eine
befürworterin strenger lockdown wenn sie
diese bilder von den öffnungen heute
sehen wie kommentieren sie das
sehr viel spielraum in dem moment wo man
öffnet in dem moment wo es mir kontakt
gibt es auch möglicherweise wieder mehr
infektionen das kann man ausgleichen das
kann man über stellt das ausgleichen
es kam immer mehr vorsicht und hamas
nahm ausgleichen
das genau zu berechnen ist eine relativ
schwierige sache dann schauen wir uns
gleich im verlauf des gesprächs mal an
wie man das voraussehen kann was
vielleicht aus ihrer sicht gut wäre und
was detailliert nicht so gut wäre
schauen aber zuerst mal tatsächlich zu
luisa houben nach magdeburg ins pflanzt
center dort wo es genau so bunt ist wie
wir das eben auch gesehen haben in den
bildern die wir gerade eingespielt haben
und falls wir frau briesemann nicht mehr
sehen sondern luisa houben sehen richtig
da ist sie und das grün sehr unruhig
drumherum hallo luisa jetzt sehen wir
dich und jetzt kann ich dich auch fragen
wie war denn der erste tag dort heute in
magdeburg
pünktlich zum meteorologischen
frühlingsanfang der ist ja heute hat
sich der ein oder andere magdeburger die
eine oder andere magdeburgerin sich
heute mit frischen topfpflanzen mit
frischen kräutern eindecken können ich
habe mit ein paar kundinnen hier des
gartencenters eben gesprochen
wir waren eine gruppe von freunden dabei
die gerade frisch zusammen gezogen ist
und die sagten endlich haben sie die
gelegenheit sich neue zimmerpflanzen
kaufen zu können
es war aber auch ein pärchen dabei die
gesagt haben wir haben endlich für ein
neues ausflugsziel sie sind hierher
gekommen haben auch kräuter gekauft für
die küche aber sagten endlich gibt es
mal ein neues ziel was sie besuchen
können und bei mir ist eine
mitarbeiterin des gartencenters vor
daniels wie war denn der erste tag
berichten sie mal ja also wir waren alle
sehr aufgeregt auf das was heute kommt
wir haben wirklich die ganze letzte
woche nur gewirtschaftet und natürlich
alles für pico bello hinzustellen dass
der kunde wenn er reinkommt natürlich
auch wieder die freude bei uns hat war
denn viel los ja also relativ ruhig war
es bei uns jetzt sind andere zeiten
gewöhnt und ja aber ich denke das wird
ja ist ja doch also der ein oder andere
ist auf jeden fall unterwegs auf dem
parkplatz ist auch doch recht viel los
fand ich es auf jeden fall eher
ungewohnt wenn man es kennt sonst total
leer wie seit mitte dezember hatten sie
ja geschlossen
wir haben sie sich denn auf den tag
heute vorbereitet also wir haben
natürlich alles mögliche getan um das
hygiene konzept durchzuführen wir haben
für den kunden wagen waschanlage da kann
der kunde wirklich da einen
einkaufswagen desinfizieren er kann
seine hände desinfizieren wir haben hier
sämtliche gene spender zu stehen
ja unsere abstandshalter also wir tun
wirklich alles mögliche und den kunden
natürlich hier auch bei uns sicherheit
zu gewährleisten
der laden ist ja auch relativ groß
mehrere hundert quadratmeter und sie
lassen trotzdem noch 400 kunden auch
hier rein heute wie klappt das denn die
abstände werden die eingehalten
wie ist das feedback der content also es
klappt super
es hält sich jeder an die abstandsregeln
wie gesagt wir wollen auch immer wieder
wie begeistert sie auch von unserer
desinfektion samt einkaufswagen sind
also wir können uns wirklich nicht
beschweren es klappt super
ok also ja große freude bei den
kundinnen und auch bei den
mitarbeiterinnen dass es hier wieder
losging heute luisa ich habe noch eine
frage was ist denn am meisten verkauft
worden waren es tatsächlich die früher
weil es alle jetzt nach draußen zieht
oder wann es grünpflanzen fürs zimmer
weil niemand die eigenen vier wände mehr
ertragen kann oder was was wurde am
meisten gefragt was was würde denn am
meisten nachgefragt was haben die
menschen heute gekauft also am meisten
ist natürlich die frühjahrsblüher wie
die stiefmütterchen und veilchen und die
primeln natürlich ein bisschen zu hause
wieder haben
er hat das triste sozusagen muss lernen
und einfach mal ein bisschen freude
wieder zu hause zu haben
ein bisschen abwechslung im schotter und
auf jeden fall super vielen dank dann
erstmal danke nach magdeburg kurzem
nicht mit langem
herzlichen dank nach magdeburg für den
moment und willkommen
nachher im verlauf der sendung noch mal
zu euch zurück ganz kurz an dieser
stelle die freude über die frühblüher
teilen natürlich alle die die pflanzen
lieben die freude darüber dass die
friseure wieder offen haben teilen alle
die die heute beim friseur waren konnte
friseur sein konnten wie zum beispiel
nico dext er schreibt über youtube ich
war heute so glücklich dass friseure
wieder auf haben habe da mein ganzes
geld verbraucht auch noch mal dass das
nicht ganz stimmt vielen dank für den
kommentar und an der stelle noch mal der
hinweise immer euro und ihre fragen und
kommentare wie immer in die
kommentarspalten von facebook und
youtube oder per e mail wenn er oder sie
die zdf- heute- app nutzt an diese
eingeblendete adresse
wir schauen uns mal an wie es denn in
den gartencentern außerhalb von
magdeburg so ausgesehen hat daniela
sonntag hat sich umgeschaut baumärkte
friseure in deutschland an diesem ersten
märz 2021 oben 10 an den seiten 4
millimeter endlich ein vernünftiger
haarschnitt ein ganz neues lebensgefühl
für jörg neblung
jetzt kann ich wieder wie hier in erfurt
darf ab heute bundesweit wieder geföhnt
und geschnitten werden unter strengen
auflagen zehn quadratmeter pro kunde
heißt viele verlängern die
öffnungszeiten und arbeiten in schichten
in vielen bundesländern wie hier in
brandenburg öffnen heute auch wieder
floristen und gartenmärkte gärtner
erleichtert dass die frühere nicht auf
den kompost müssen
es sind jetzt die haupt monat die dikom
märz april mai wir haben glück gehabt
dass es zwei ruhige monate waren wo wir
zu wahren das jetzt wo der hauptumsatz
ist wir wie offenheit und die besinnung
zur natur zum eigenen garten zum schönen
balkon wird bleiben mode händlerin anja
scheinpflug aus erfurt hat auch saison
ware im laden dass sie nicht öffnen darf
macht sie wütend
es ist hier mittlerweile eine zweierlei
maß messen und das kann einfach so nicht
mehr sein ohne uns stirbt erfuhr
dutzende einzelhändler haben derzeit
diese plakate im schaufenster
verständnis für den ärger hat auch
friseur unternehmer jens kleingünther in
erfurt und trotzdem ist der heilfroh
dass seine angestellten jetzt wieder
umsatz machen und trinkgeld bekommen
dass wir die ersten sein dürfen die
öffnen
das ist also wenn ich dann die
gastronomie im vergleich ist das schon
toll dass wir das sein dürfen einziges
problem überhaupt noch einen termin
bekommen die nächsten paar tage ist hier
erst mal alles ausgebucht
tja damit sind wir wieder bei ihnen frau
doktor briesemann in göttingen
sie haben vorhin gesagt sie sind eine
befürworterin von niedrigen zahlen jetzt
schauen wir uns an was er gerade gesehen
haben teilweise gibt es wieder öffnungen
die sieben tage inzidenz liegt derzeit
bei 65,8 in erfurt was wir gerade im
beitrag gesehen haben liegt sie derzeit
bei 79 wie gut ist es da jetzt friseure
zu öffnen
nun könnten ihm ist es dass in dem
moment war in den innenräumen trifft in
dem moment mal in ihrer kontakte können
sie uns eine infektion kann unterstütze
ich nicht 100 prozent für meinen lassen
die ruine konzepte sind rezepte sind gut
und richtig und die haben sich ja auch
sehr sehr gut verbessert in dieser zu
denen ich mein letzter gestartet sind
aber auch jedes jedes konzept hat seine
tücken
insofern geht man davon aus dass räte
darauf jedenfalls irgendwelchen
anstiegen von fallzahlen wieder kommt
ich bin die person der zahlen das ist
manchmal nicht so schön wie die personen
der blumen in den baum zu sein oder in
den garten zentrum
wenn wir auf die zahlen schauen sehen
wir dass das r
es ist das ist zwischen 1,95 meter
vielleicht ein bisschen höher wenn das
so bleibt dann sind die
intensivstationen ersten drei vier fünf
monaten volk vielleicht ist also
schneller geimpft als in den schnee als
intensivstation voll sind in arbeit ist
er wird wieder steigt auf 1 vermeiden
sondern als nummer zwei nächte jeweils
nicht nicht weit weg ist dann sind die
intensivstation hat war wesentlich
früher wieder voll und damit muss man
rechnen also wenn ich bin absolut
verstehen sie mich nicht falsch aber
nicht auf kosten von steigenden
fallzahlen
denn irgendwann steht man dann wieder
vor dem problem vor dem wir im november
gestand bei der entscheidung was machen
nähe mit dem intensivstationen die
wieder toll sind das problem ist eben
das exponentielle wachstum mit nerven
und eines konferenz dauert es halt ein
zwei drei monate bis die intensivstation
möglicherweise wieder an dem mit sind
wenn das erstmals steigt das ist ja
nicht besonders viel mehr dann ist es
eventuell schon in 1 200 und in dem
zeitraum zweiter nicht genug gegen das
auszugleichen
das heißt sie würden befürworten erstmal
so weiter machen mit den schließungen
wie wir sie bisher haben oder würden sie
sagen nein wenn wir sehen dass
wahrscheinlich die britische mutationen
oder auch die südafrikanische mutation
anstecken wir sind dann müssten wir
eigentlich das gegenteil von dem machen
was wir gerade machen dann dürften wir
nämlich nicht locker sondern man müssten
wir quasi noch mehr zurückfahren konnten
sie hier sind wahnsinnig jedes bin ich
also dafür alles zuzulassen
der schnelltest wir müssen sehr sehr
sinnvoll diese schnelltests einsetzt so
sehen das die kontakt nachverfolgung
wirklich so schnell wie möglich geht im
prinzip auf jedem 1
und personen etwas beitragen wenn man
den verdacht hat dass man coda positiv
sein könnte
die bekannten und die freunde die man
getroffen hat auch selbst informieren
damit sie das virus nicht weiter tragen
niedrige fall sein haben einfach die in
allen bereichen vorteile für die
wirtschaft für die gesellschaft für die
gesundheit sowieso und sie verwahren uns
davor dass man in einigen wochen wieder
vor der situation stehen wir wieder
schließen oder nicht
am ende ist es aber das ist ganz klar
eine güterabwägung wenn die entscheidung
der gesellschaft ist jetzt weitgehend zu
öffnen im zweifel mit dem risiko
steigender fallzahlen dann ist das eine
entscheidung der gesellschaft main mit
er habe ich ja schon gesagt sind die
zahlen und bei den zahlen ist es ein
gewisses waffen ist ganz ohne frage das
andere was wir auch noch bedenken
sollten wir haben nicht lange gesagt
wenn man unter 15
im bereich hinter 50 dass man dort doch
anfangen könnte zu lockern und es gibt
viele landkreise die in dem bereich sind
und da ist eben die fragen ob man das
nicht auch lokal differenzieren machen
kann so über schulen die hier wirklich
regionalen sind beim einzelhandel muss
man schauen wie die mobilität ist das
mandat das immer single bedingungen
passt weil sie die schulen gerade
angesprochen haben
hier fragt ein user namens andrea es
über youtube frau dr briesemann sind die
meisten ansteckungen nicht in der schule
in der kita und zu hause
nun sind sie keine virologin das können
sie natürlich in der hinsicht nicht
beantworten aber vielleicht können sie
anhand der modellierungen die sie ja
auch machen in ihrem institut sagen
welche auswirkungen der schul öffnungen
oder schließungen auf den verlauf der
pandemie haben expertise von wo welche
anstrengungen stattfinden mit ihm schon
bald dass es
was wir wissen die meisten ansteckungen
passieren im haushalt zu hause und es
lässt sich auch schwer vermeiden wenn ja
nicht wie von mir mitglieder in
irgendeiner form von einander trennen
dass diese frage schon nicht gut
vermeiden
und dann ist die frage was noch offen
ließ wir haben zum beispiel im letzten
november gesehen in england der wahl
lockdown alle schulen waren erhoffen und
dann sieht man das unter den umständen
von lotto mit offenen schulen die schuld
an den hauptteil der infektion beitragen
und fange ich mir bei als andere orte wo
man sich in innenräumen trifft die nicht
besonders gut belüftet sind sondern sie
tragen einfach genauso wie überall wo
man sich eben auch trifft insofern ist
es daher für die erste welle kann man
sagen dass die schulschließung wenn
zusammen mit der universität schließung
etwa 20 bis 30 prozent reduktion im meer
gebracht haben das ist relativ viel das
ist so viel wie jetzt auch die neue
variante aus ändern dich die space and 7
möglicherweise beiträgt so für die
größenordnung
aber es ist ganz schwer vorherzusagen
und der dabei was zu berechnen ob jetzt
dieses schulhöfen in den wechselmodell
und schule öffnen einen besseren hygiene
konzepten ob das ebenso wie beiträgt
wenigen und beträgt hier kommt eine
weitere frage von heiko plumps über
facebook was ich nicht verstehe die zahl
der neuinfektionen sinken doch
schwankungen gibt es natürlich immer
warum ist dann der wert über 1 soweit
ich das verstanden habe steigt die zahl
der neuinfektionen zuletzt wieder aber
trotzdem können sie vielleicht diesen
widerspruch auflösen und die zahl der
neuinfektionen steigt sie langsam
also die finnen sind inspiriert von 60
jetzt sind sie eher richtung 66 wieder
für ganz deutschland langsam steigt sie
deswegen genau deswegen
er werde auch über 1 das was aber
eigentlich der sage ich mal schwierige
respekt es ist folgende die anzahl von
personen wirklich die absolute anzahl
die sich mit der neue mit den alten
varianten angesteckt harmonie hin zurück
die absolute anzahl von menschen die
sich mit der 94 17 varianten stecken die
steigt und dann kann man sich vorstellen
dass es irgendwann von der feinen kurve
und der steigenden kurve die sind
überall gibt wo dann die neue variante
überhand nimmt und deswegen erwartet man
genau das was wir gerade sehen ganz ohne
der verhaltensänderung dass die fallzahl
langsam was ich hier wieder steigen aber
auch so ein problem natürlich könnte man
sagen jetzt sind ja die älteren schon
geimpft
zumindest ein teil von denen die
todesfälle und die anzahl dort geht er
auch weiter zurück das ist ja wunderbar
das problem ist nur bis die 50 bis 60
jährigen zum beispiel wir haben noch
einige monate vergehen und für jeden
einzelnen in der altersgruppe 40 bis 60
ist die wahrscheinlichkeit zu versterben
nicht extrem hoch die s group im bereich
von vielleicht malen prozent deutlich
weniger noch aber die gesamtzahl dadurch
dass das jahr 20 millionen menschen sind
und es sehr viele die möglicherweise auf
die intensivstation müssten wenn sie
sich infizieren uns das viel mehr
erklärt ensi stationen durchhalten und
deswegen heißt es die nächste welle
trifft dann im vermehrt auch schöne
spielverläufen die höheren menschen und
das ist etwas was genau überlegen was
als gesellschaft auch wir das wollten
ein erlebnis einfach ja waren sie das
gerne genau die nächste welle trifft
eben familien an die jüngeren die noch
nicht geimpft sind und die
intensivstationen werden leider auch mit
denen gefüllt werden können
nun trifft natürlich die angst der
menschen die immer noch sehr groß ist
die angst vor ansteckung die angst einen
schweren verlauf zu haben die ist ja
immer noch sehr präsent in der
gesellschaft die trifft aber
gleichzeitig auf eine unglaubliche
corona maßnahmen müdigkeit und auf eine
hoffnung dass man bald wieder mehr kann
als man in den letzten monaten konnte
und das schöne wetter bestärkt dass er
quasi nur
doch man hat das gefühl man möchte
einfach wieder aktiv sein möchte
rausgehen man möchte leute treffen das
spiegelt sich hier auch in den in den
kommentaren wieder dennis bmg schreibt
zum beispiel über facebook
lasst die baumärkte einzelhandel und
gastronomen auch wieder ihren job machen
und öffnen mit hygiene konzept und
regeln geht es im supermarkt her auch
also warum nicht da franken schreibt
über facebook was macht das für einen
unterschied ob man im penny einkauft
oder zum beispiel bei obi oder im
hagebaumarkt oder in irgendeinem anderen
einzelhändler im baumarkt hat man sogar
mehr platz als beim friseur auf engstem
raum aero sohle auszutauschen
also man kann hier sehen produkte
briesemann die menschen wünschen sich
normalität und alltag und das ist ja
auch eine wirtschaftliche frage weil
viele existenzen ja auch daran hängen
jetzt wollte ich noch einmal auf die
zahlen eingehen die sie genannt haben
auch in dem was sie veröffentlicht haben
in bezug auf die nachverfolgung da haben
sie gesagt dass der kipp punkt ab dem
die gesundheitsämter nachverfolgung
machen können bei zehn bis zwanzig liegt
im moment haben wir wie gesagt eine
inzidenz von 65,8 es gab mal zielwert
von 50 dann gab es ein incidents wert
von 35 das was sie da von 10 und 20 in
aussicht stellen das scheint ja
unerreichbar aus jetziger sicht
wir haben im letzten herbst gesehen hat
die fallzahlen also im letzten sommer
sind die fallzahlen langsam gestiegen so
langsam dass man es fast gar nicht
richtig wahrgenommen haben und jeden
monat verdoppelt
bis dann im september/oktober diese
intelligenz von 20 erreicht worden ist
und dort hat sich dann diese steht
selbst beschleunigt daher kommt diese
zahlten sich die zahl von 354 wissen wir
woher die kommen das ist komponistin
letzten früher gewesen
dort sind ja auch lange deutlich drunter
gewesen stz dass die 20 erreicht weil
das der fall gefallen wenn man dieses
ziel hat ja und das ist auch für uns auf
den zielwert im letzten herbst wenn wir
uns andere hatten ihr wesen die mehr
kontakt als erst der einzelhandel bei
auf dem der restaurants waren offen
das heißt da gab es sehr sehr viele
kontakte jetzt ist die kontakta
verfolgung einfach jetzt finde
gesundheitsämter auch mehr fälle
nachverfolgt und stoppen
das bedeutet dass es auch kein fester
grenzwert sondern es würde eigentlich im
idealfall im idealfall wirst dich am
liebsten wenn alle paten gesundheitsamt
und positive pcr-test die kontakte zu
verfolgen wenn das dann innerhalb von
ein zwei tagen passiert ist klasse dann
könnte man das als den richtwert nehmen
die inzidenz allein ist nicht der ideale
berg arzt sagen sehr guter wert gerade
also wir haben gelernt damit die zu
interpretieren und um damit umzugehen
und zu verstehen wie sieht das
infektionsgeschehen widerspiegelt
insofern die cd 20ten ziel weil wir
wissen dass wir darin auch mit offenen
geschäften mit offenen restaurants und
mit offenen schulen eigentlich ein
stabiles infektionsgeschehen erreichen
können
stabil ist infektionsgeschehen erreichen
macht sie das eigentlich als
wissenschaftlerin völlig irre dass die
gesundheitsämter nicht schneller sind
bei der daten nach verfolgung weil es
den deutschen datenschutz gibt der für
viele so hoch steht dass er nicht als
grundrecht eingeschränkt wird im
gegensatz zu anderen grundrechten man
könnte ja auch sagen man macht diese app
so dass sie mehr bringt als sie im
moment tut und kann damit die kontakte
viel schneller nachverfolgen und kann
dann vielleicht auch an anderen stellen
einfach flexibler sein
dieser aspekt wird natürlich viel
diskutiert der wird uns vor allen dingen
helfen herauszufinden wie möglich
weil die öffentlichen verkehrsmittel
einzelhandel in den restaurants wirklich
stattfinden weil das ja etwas extrem
schwer nachzuverfolgen ist wenn die
person sich nicht kennen was die
eindämmung selber angeht haben wir
selber nach verdächtigen gezeigt dass
die kontakte nach erfolgen da nicht
perfekt sein muss die meisten kontakte
die man hat mit dem man wirklich
intensiven kontakt hat da kennt man die
namen das sind die freunde die bekannten
die arbeitskollegen da weiß man
normalerweise wen man in den letzten
zwei wochen auch intensiv getroffen hat
dann haltet auch genau diese person für
die kontakt nachverfolgung dann im kann
athen zu schicken man kann nicht jedes
mal den ganzen bus den ganze u bahn
unterliegt alle personen die
gleichzeitig im baumarkt waren in
quarantäne schicken das heißt für die
kontaktnahme würde würde sondern app
nicht viel weiterhelfen
für das wissen wo infektion
wahrscheinlich stattgefunden haben dann
würde es deutlich etwas bringen
nun blicken wir natürlich am anfang
dieser woche alle gebannt auf mittwoch
das tut auch ex oma ismaili über youtube
gestellt die frage wann werden die
anderen geschäfte öffnen und diese frage
wird wahrscheinlich am mittwoch
beantwortet wenn sich die
bundeskanzlerin und die
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten der länder mal
wieder zu einem gipfel zusammen schalten
die politik diskutiert schon vorher was
zu tun ist vor allem vor dem hintergrund
dass die lage in einigen bundesländern
ganz besonders schwierig ist
bayern und sachsen schlagen alarm
tschechien ist nah und die nächste bund
länder konferenz ebenfalls gemeinsam
werden die beiden ministerpräsidenten
erstens für mehr impfstoff für ihre
regionen und zweitens dafür das
impfkonzept insgesamt zu überarbeiten es
wird sonst nur eine art mangelverwaltung
werden also mit einem überbürokratisiert
system kommen wir nicht weiter deswegen
spätestens april also spätestens wenn
der ganz große anteil vom impfstoff
kommt muss jede dose impfstoff verimpft
werden wo es nur geht die bund länder
runde am mittwoch auch dies eine
forderung der beiden die daran
teilnehmen werden könne keinesfalls
große lockerungen beschließen
jetzt die chance das modell was wir bei
unserem nachbarn sehen sei es in
österreich oder der tschechischen
republik oder auch in frankreich zu
verhindern dass wir in eine
wellenbewegung kommen öffnen schließen
schließen öffnen ein ständiges hin und
her das kann niemand wollen
genau das aber passiert gerade in
kretschmanns bundesland im vogtland
machen grundschulen und kitas schon
wieder dicht eltern schwanken zwischen
verzweiflung und resignation
aber nachdem man bei einer incidents
über 100 die grundschulen und kitas
wieder geöffnet hat war eigentlich
absehbar dass die entwicklung dahin geht
dass bei steigenden zahlen die schulen
kitas wieder geschlossen werden müssen
naja wir warten eigentlich schon sein
letztes jahr langfristige tragfähige
konzepte und die kann man nicht erkennen
große hoffnungen ruhen jetzt auf
schnelltests eigentlich hatten sie von
heute an bereits zur verfügung stehen
sollen doch bundesgesundheitsminister
sparen scheiterte mit seinem konzept
heute nun ein papier aus seinem hause
nach zdf-informationen schlägt er vor
dass alle bürger von märz an
zwei mal pro woche kostenlos getestet
werden sollen vorerst bis ende juni zwei
tage noch bis zur nächsten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz gesucht
wird eine langfriststrategie im wettlauf
gegen das virus
der vdr briesemann wie sähe denn die
langfriststrategie aus ihrer sicht aus
oder ist das wort langfriststrategie
schon etwas woran sie sich stören wie
möglich erkennen dass es nicht mehr zu
unerkannten tränen gibt es auch probleme
die schläger nicht wissen dass wir das
gerüst cargo das dann aus versehen
weiter verbreitet als sie das wollen
mein wunsch für eine langfriststrategie
wäre der freizeit wirklich konsequent
niedrig zu halten und die öffnungen
regung zu kompensieren zu begleiten
durch diese sehr engmaschige testen was
wir uns alle bewusst sein müssen überall
dort wo man sich ihnen trifft dann wird
es auch zum ansteckungen kommen dass es
bekannt vor den nazis aus england aus
vielen anderen ländern
es wird also auch zu einer erhöhung des
infektionsgeschehen führen wenn diese
verschiedenen allerdings wieder mehr
treffen gibt dass das absolut zu
erwarten meine hoffnung ist dass der
einstieg so langsam ist dass wir mit der
info schneller sind aber wie gesagt das
dauert monate bis genug menschen gegen
bieten
frau dr viola briesemann vielen dank für
ihre einschätzung vielen dank für die es
expertise und da sind wir gespannt was
am mittwoch tatsächlich entschieden wird
und damit gehen wir noch mal zurück ins
land center nach magdeburg und zu luisa
luisa es in wenigen sekunden 19 uhr dann
schließt das pflanze aber ihr dürft noch
da sein und wie ist denn die stimmung
dort unter den kunden und auch bei der
mitarbeiterinnen mit der duh sprechen
kannst welche erwartungen gibt es denn
da an den gipfel am mittwoch genau hier
ist jetzt gleich feierabend die letzten
kunden sind gerade an der kasse und
bezahlt ihren einkauf und frau dann
jetzt hat eben schon erzählt so ist es
ja heute gar nicht so viel los gewesen
wie sie vielleicht gedacht hätte aber
sie haben eben gesagt sie erwarte schon
dass es in nächster zeit doch auch
wieder voller wird oder ja also erwarten
dass schon heute hatten schon sehr viele
kunden angerufen
und nachgefragt ob er überhaupt wieder
auf haben also es wird es wird wir sind
da sehr zuversichtlich
ich muss erstmal überall ankommen und
dann haben wir auch unsere kunden wieder
bei uns im laden bei dem ein oder
anderen noch die vorsichtig sich auch
und zu eine zu grosse menschenmenge zu
geben wenn jetzt sich am mittwoch die
ministerpräsidentin und die
bundeskanzlerin wieder treffen und
zusammen setzen und ja vielleicht zu dem
entschluss kommen dass diese öffnungen
zu voreilig waren weil es sind ja
mutationen unterwegs die fallzahlen
steigen wieder leicht was ist da ihre
erwartungen werden sie einverstanden
wenn sie vielleicht schließen müssten
also es werfe uns denke ich auch eine
absolute katastrophe
wir sind nicht ohne grund verkäufer
gebrochen wir lieben unsere kunden wir
freuen uns jedes mal wenn die kunden zu
uns kommen und ich denke die kunden
sehen das genauso also wir plädieren
eigentlich auch generell dazu dass der
einzelhandel eigentlich wieder
aufgemacht werden sollte einfach auch ja
die hygienevorschriften einhalten und
dann denke ich wird es trotzdem so jeden
diese zuversicht derartige ja wir sind
zuversichtlich dass sie die
hygiene-vorschriften hier einhalten
können und so hoffen sie hier im
gartencenter dass sie auch weiterhin
offen bleiben dürfen
grün ist die hoffnung luisa houben
vielen herzlichen dank für diese
eindrücke nach magdeburg und jetzt haben
wir pünktlich zu ladenschluss fast
pünktlich geschafft liebe zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer ich danke ihnen herzlich
fürs mitmachen mit kommentieren und
fragen und zuschauen und zuhören und
sage an dieser stelle des und bis morgen
abend